[Music]
with Christmas just around the corner
Germany's capital is decked out for the
holidays glitter and glamour abound like
here at the brandenburg gate on the
boulevard unter den linden and on the
Kurfurstendamm a shopping tour along the
festively illuminated streets is a must
during the holiday season for visitors
and Berlin residents alike Berlin's top
address for Christmas shopping is the
cow hostess vest and orchid ave for
short germany's best-known department
store the decorations on the facade are
already enough to attract people
this year Santa's little helpers play a
starring role in the display windows
they help prepare for the holidays at
Qadhafi's Christmas workshop it's part
of the stores tradition to elaborately
decorated swindles in the Christmas
season
with more than 60,000 square meters of
floor space the Khedive a is one of
Europe's biggest department stores up to
a hundred and eighty thousand customers
come every day about forty percent of
them are tourists at this time of year
they're all looking for presents and
Christmas decorations
santa claus will be in the middle of it
all right through Christmas Eve for many
a photo with him is an essential part of
a festive shopping trip just how DB
economy is a very old tradition more
than a hundred years old by myself AM
800 years old I've watched it grow from
the very beginning but that's a
different story cadete has many
international visitors and it's Santa
Claus now has fans all over the world
[Music]
for many families attending a
performance of a fairy tale as an
integral part of the Christmas season
stories from Grimm's fairy tales are
staged into rustic wooden huts in the
heart of Berlin there are up to five
different performances every day
[Music]
producer christian schulz and his
theatre group came up with the idea in
2005 young he conceived the fairy tales
for children and parents would come with
their kids but the later in the evening
a performance took place the more adults
were in the audience now we stayed even
more performances for adults than for
children the Christmas season is a fairy
tale time that's we didn't invent that I
thought bnef would the repertoire
includes world famous fairy tales like
Cinderella Snow White and Hansel and
Gretel the story of a brother and sister
whose parents have been dened them in
the forest and who end up in a witch's
house nibble like a mouse who is
nibbling here on my house the wind the
wind heavens can the actors have their
own interpretation of the fairy tales
but of course Hansel and Gretel still
has a happy ending the performers always
like to involve the audience
munir money kid no you should ask my
kids what it was lovely I liked it
[Music]
another German tradition is visiting
Christmas markets in Berlin has more
than 60 of them one of the most
enchanting is on gendarmenmarkt square
it attracts some 800,000 visitors from
around the world each year most everyone
tries an original cheering of brought
four star thuringian sausage they're
made in accordance with the recipe
that's over 600 years old with
seasonings like margarine and caraway
seeds another specialty is mulled wine
made from heating red wine with cloves
cinnamon and anise its unmistakable
scent is a traditional component of the
Christmas season in Germany defeated
octave of salina nuts or from any people
part of looking forward to Christmas is
going to the Christmas market the year
is over and people celebrate that in
small groups with a delicious mug of
mulled wine and Berlin is famous for the
Christmas lights and decorations on the
CUDA until early January the Grand
Boulevard is transformed into a three
and a half kilometer long sea of lights